Andrew human what's your thoughts on him
one of the only individuals that I
believe to be like dedicated to putting
out the best information even at the
detriment of potential views and he's
very open to criticism even from
YouTubers who aren't medically qualified
like myself he did not get upset or
annoyed when I first reacted to one of
his Rogan episodes and I had talked
about and some of the stuff he said
about some of the bodybuilding he had
mentioned some of the interactions with
endocrine hormones I kind of did one of
my classic reaction videos like a lot of
people could take that the wrong way and
be like I'm a world top tier
neuroscientist and you piece of YouTuber
you don't know anything who are you to
talk about this he was not like that at
all we've become decent friends I would
say since then he's always open to
learning even if it's from people who
aren't medically credentialed yeah he's
great